I want to deal with the number that must
be the most requested so far on
numberphile and that is 301 now for
those of you who don't pay much
attention to the YouTube view counters
you might wonder what the big deal is
with 301 and let me tell you when a new
video is uploaded and if it's quite a
popular one you'll quickly see the view
counter rise and rise and rise and then
it will get to 301 and it will freeze
and it will stay on 301 for a day maybe
half a day and then it will start
counting to higher numbers as usual now
a lot of people have been very mystified
by this and have asked us to check it
out I'm Ted Hamilton I am a product
manager for YouTube analytics so there
you go I've got in touch with the people
who actually count the YouTube views
that is correct well we actually have
the computers do it we don't count them
ourselves but yes so before we get to
this whole 301 malarkey what is a view
on YouTube
I've always wondered is someone just
pressing play accounting as a view well
that's actually a bit of a YouTube
secret a view should be a video playback
that was requested by an actual user who
got what they were intending to get and
had a good user experience we think of
views as a currency and therefore we
have to make a significant effort to
eliminate counterfeit Meuse if you will
now I know that all sounds a bit
mysterious
and we will come back to it later on in
the video but let's crack on with this
301 figure and you're gonna find out
counterfeit views actually have a bit to
do with it but the next thing we need to
realize is when you watch any video like
this one for example you're probably not
all watching it from the same server it
gets distributed all around the world so
there is you know what the original
which which you will have uploaded I
guess by the time you're watching this
have already uploaded then this gets
what do you call cashed in different
locations so that when you make a
request for a video it doesn't need to
travel all the way from from London you
know over to California and say okay
send me back all of these bytes way back
here
so with multiple copies of the video all
around the world
counting the views starts to get a
little bit more complicated here's you
at your
at your computer watching the video if
you make a request to this server this
server is going to give you the video
right and at the same time this server
is gonna write a little message to a log
it's just one line in a log in a while
we collect all of these logs
so we'll ship this thing in from Central
Europe or whatever into the central log
collection area aggregate them all
together and then go through and count
among well okay that seems simple enough
but it doesn't explain why the view
count to Fraser's views as mentioned are
a currency when you have a video with
with a you know very small amount of
views then you don't need to be too
careful about what you know what that
view was over once it gets to be you
know above 300 and beyond this currency
we really need to verify and make sure
that the number is what it purports to
be so this means that we have to go
through a statistical verification
process and that statistical
verification process actually takes some
time and thus we go from incrementing
one by one to then saying okay now we're
incrementing in batch and all of these
views that have been added on have been
verified by YouTube to be real views we
are preventing things like you know BOTS
to go in and you know I had a bunch of
views to a video or we are preventing
something that you know may have perhaps
you know mislead someone into into
watching a video you know say you had a
title that was completely misleading and
a thumbnail that was completely
misleading and and people actually went
on there and and just viewed for a few
seconds and then left you know if you
see that enough times it's it's a fair
enough indicator that you know something
was wrong there so that we might not
authorize all of those to be legitimate
views all right then they're verifying
the numbers they're checking everything
I guess we probably could have guessed
that
but why 301 I was not there when the
decision was made but at some point the
decision was made that we need to draw a
line between what is innocuous and the
database can handle and what
is all of a sudden serious business the
proportion was calculated to be you know
at about 300 that you know this is the
portion that we need to take care of but
the formula that we used to arrive at
three zero zero I don't know if anyone
actually knows that well okay they draw
a line in the sand it was kind of
arbitrary they wanted to differentiate
between people just sharing their home
movies and the videos that are more
popular the ones that are a bit more
serious the ones that need scrutiny but
that was 300 the view counter freezes at
301 what's going on here is there a
reason yeah there is a reason and the
reason was the number 300 was chosen and
when someone's writing code they need to
put the logic in the code that says you
know where you should stop or where you
should if one condition is true you go
to the left and the other condition is
true you go to the right now this
condition can be written like this
if the view count is less than 300 then
go ahead and add one to the view count
otherwise go to X where X is our you
know much more complicated view count
pipeline however what actually got
written was not this but if you count is
less than or equal to 300 then increment
the view count so what this means is if
the view count is at 300 this says is
the view count less than or equal to 300
yes it is let me add one so then you end
up at 301 let me recap what's going on
here
the code which is controlling where this
view counter phrases contains a less
than or equals to sign so that means
when a new early view comes along it's
checked against the code say the overall
view count on the database is 299 okay
then we'll let another one on here comes
another view
now the view count is 300 that isn't
less than 300 but it is equal to 300 so
the code let's another view jump on to
the total now we're at 301 and when
another view comes along it's not less
than 300 but it's also not equal to 300
anymore and the door is shut there were
going to be no more views added to the
publicly visible count until YouTube
have done their checks and that will
take half a day to a day then of course
all the extra views that have been
counted in the interim all pile onto the
total nothing's missed at least that's
what I'm told
yeah so whoever wrote this code probably
did not realize the magnitude of what
they were doing this view counts have
been around since the beginning of
YouTube and you know who was to know
what YouTube would become so yeah it
that was actually a rather monumental
second of time in San Bruno California
when a coder decided to write that logic
in and is now one of the idiosyncrasies
of YouTube now I can hear some of you
screaming at your computer screens the
view count doesn't stop at 301 sometimes
it stops at 302 or 305 or 310 what's
going on there there's an explanation
for that too
and that comes back to how I was saying
the videos are shared around servers all
across the world so here's what's going
on there the views are coming in from
the logs at the different videos the
different places around the world and
they're coming to this central database
and we know the door is going to be shot
at 301 we just explained that a minute
ago but what happens if views are coming
in at the same time someone watched it
in Africa at the exact same time someone
watched in Europe now we've got multiple
views coming in checking if they're
allowed to join the count yes they are
it's less than or equal to 300 so they
all pile on at the same time now when a
new view comes along sorry we're closed
for business
but because of that simultaneous update
a few extra views were able to sneak on
we get asked about it all the time
it's I wouldn't say that it causes angst
but it's certainly I would classify it
more as an annoyance you can go and see
a very popular video and you look and
you'll see that it has two thousand
likes and three hundred views that's a
little bit interesting well that the
issue there is that we don't put the
likes through the same rigor same
rigorous process and likes are far fewer
in magnitude so are our systems can
handle them more easily but the the
views do freeze and it can result in
some awkward situations but that
actually results in terrific videos like
this I did speak to Ted for maybe 45 50
minutes and recorded at all I've got
loads of footage a lot more detail
including a bit more about what
constitutes a view and I know some of
you will want to see it I haven't had
time to edit it all just yet but stay
tuned because I'll be uploading that to
numberphile in the near future and for
those of you who don't like these ones
that are a bit more about computers and
the internet I'm sorry
numberphile is always unpredictable and
I promise next time it might be
something you enjoy a bit more right how
many how many arrows do you want so the
next one let's say we did three ^ ^ ^
arrow arrow or whatever you want to call
this three will that that